she has been so brave right from the
start
maria kolesnikova with the smile red
lipstick and the heart sign which were
always her trademarks with her political
associate maxim znack who saw in his
40th birthday on sunday in jail
sentenced to 11 and 10 years
respectively for supposedly plotting to
bring down alexander lukashenko's regime
the courtroom today the first time in a
year that kolesnikova's father has seen
his daughter in the flesh
outside the courtroom cheers for her
defence team who promised to fight on
was one of three women to run on a joint
ticket in last year's presidential
elections
she then famously ripped up her passport
rather than be forced into exile an
incredible act of defiance in the face
of the most vicious crackdown in europe
since stalin's times
[Music]
but belarus's president seems to have
settled into his pariah role
this portrait a birthday present
revealed today marking a key moment in
the crackdown on last year's
demonstrations
and if this was belarus a year ago no
one dares to protest now they know they
have too much to lose
diana magnay sky news moscow